no more time at the bar for groups of
friends
in london's covent garden weekend plans
brought forward fitting in a final night
out
before the mixing ban began we went for
dinner
for my birthday and before lockdown
basically
in the college environment we're all
mingling anyway yeah so
being out and having to separate it's
just
not very fun we're just going out for a
meal on our fridays because it's our
night off and then we're back to
studying on monday
so this is your final light as a group
yeah i want to protect people i don't
want to spread it i still
i still worry about people whether or
not i know them or not
rising covered cases pushed the capital
into tier two
but the hospitality industry's worried
so for example here you can see
inside frenchie's restaurant they used
to serve 74 covers a night
now they'll only manage 40. before we
already were
being quite uh creative with everything
and we were building
up again we could sit in our in our
reservations
and it means that it's it's dropping
again so we can feel it like tonight
it's quite busy but we can we can see it
already tomorrow for the reservations
for tomorrow
it's already dropping they hope
customers will keep coming
but nothing's guaranteed this
is london's west end on a friday night
the streets
are silent as the city moves into tier
two for millions more people a night out
is now going to look and feel a lot
different half of england is now living
with increased limits on their lives
lancashire moving into tier three and
manchester may
follow local leaders for now resisting
pressure from westminster
until financial supports agreed many
here
feel squeezed the further up north you
come
the uh i think then the more penalized
you have become
so you kind of you do get angry
you can't do much about it because the
last the last day
is the government with different rules
for different parts of the uk
there is a fear this fragmented approach
is confusing
and could undermine confidence and
compliance
laura bundock sky news